votre premier roman à succès 51 50 rue
des Ormes a été publié en 94 aujourd'hui
ça semble évident Patrick Sénégal
célèbre il va beaucoup de livres mais au
début là est-ce que ça a démarré
lentement ou rapidement non c'est moi
j'ai non non j'ai pas été la saveur du
mois en partant là moi ma carrière le
fait ça comme ça c'est vraiment été
51 50 je pense qu'on aura vendu je sais
pas la première année on a peut-être
vendu 1000 1500
c'est sûr que le film sur le seuil qui
se car le film est sorti en 2002 il
s'est passé quelque chose ça c'est clair
ça va être beaucoup de publicité là il y
a plein de gens qui ont voulu lire ce
que je faisais puis l'autre gros coup de
ma carrière celui qui a fait que j'ai pu
arrêter d'enseigner de devenir un auteur
à temps plein c'est mon roman le vide en
2007 ça c'était un autre pourquoi je
sais pas mais c'est le moment que je
remettais le plus en question pendant
l'écriture trois quatre fois j'ai fait
l'abandonner en disant ça marche pas
c'est le monde y croire pas c'est trop
ambitieux comme vraiment c'est trop
compliqué tarabiscoté tout ça finalement
mais c'est vraiment qui qui a fait le
que j'ai fait de moi l'auteur que je
suis aujourd'hui jusqu'à un certain
poids vous traversez votre crise de la
cinquantaine avec des romans comme
résonance ou critiquer les wok vous
critiquez aussi ce que vous appelez les
vieux blancs hétéros pourquoi cette
prise de parole contre l'extrémisme
parce que c'est ça moi je vais essayer
de voir extrême je voulais rire aussi
des monos extrêmes puis je voulais et
puis des fois je suis un Manon puis
mais il faut dénoncer ça l'extrême parce
que c'est des positions faciles les
positions extrêmes c'est confortable
c'est très confortable de dire je suis
work à 100% puis je suis d'accord avec
toutes les République de pas faire de
nuances comme c'est très confortable
aussi d'être un vieux con et de dire bah
tout ce qui est jeune font ils ont rien
compris les autres on a compris c'est
très confortable comme position et c'est
pas facile pour moi parce que moi aussi
il y a ceux qui me connaissent mes amis
ils savent que je suis capable d'être
très emporté je suis capable d'être
d'exploser que c'est moi-même une leçon
que je vais me donner à moi-même là
c'était fort là que je demande aux gens
je me le demande à moi aussi puis des
fois
de dire des choses qui peuvent aller
loin c'est en littérature on peut plus
atterrir on peut plus au cinéma
qui reste puis je sais je sais que j'ai
nommerai pas mais il y a des éditeurs
des qui commencent à ne pas vouloir
certains mots dans leur livre ils
veulent pas ça n'a pas de sens moi le
jour qu'un éditeur va m'empêcher
d'écrire un mot dans un de mes livres je
vais m'en aller je ne publierai pas là
c'est sûr ça c'est certain
je lui ai dit devant témoin là mais je
sais que j'en ai une star qui est pas
mais je pense pas qu'il y en a beaucoup
là je veux parler de votre processus
d'écriture parce que la musique est
omniprésente chez vous vous aimez
écouter du nine Inch nail parfois vous
chantez parfois du mode échou avec un
groupe de rock et vieux Thiam et là la
veille de cette entrevue vous étiez au
karaoké et semble-t-il que vous chantez
très bien Hardy Peas your love des Bee
Gees vous êtes bien renseigné Patrick ce
n'est qu'un
je ne vois beaucoup plus gros que
d'habitude j'ai la voix brisée j'ai
aucun aucun verre d'alcool dans le nez
non plus il manque beaucoup d'éléments
il manque beaucoup mais vous allez
recevoir
mais vous aimez ça chanter ouais ça fait
ouais ouais j'aime ça c'est pas beaucoup
de monde qui est une fois qu'ils sont
assez avec leur micro même si mais ça
fait qu'on les pousse à 14 pour les
envoyer ça à 5 une fois qu'on chantait
il faut caler une casser libérateur puis
c'est le fan c'est très très même si on
n'est pas bon même si des fois on forme
même si on est c'est un espace encore de
liberté absolue puis personne juge
personne on est juste en profite où
voulez-vous aller maintenant parce que
vous changez-t-il constamment dans les
derniers romans c'est ce qu'on apprécie
aussi bah je suis content que vous
disiez ça parce que j'essaie de me
lancer des défis d'un dernier roman
effectivement pour pas répéter c'est
faire du genre faire du roman noir comme
je le fais le piège justement la redite
parce que je sais que des lecteurs qui
voudraient que je fasse Alice deux trois
quatre cinq
deux trois quatre je sais là je me
laisser demander tout le temps mais moi
ça me trompe pas ça me prend pas ça me
tente pas ici il a fait 40 ans il faut
le même disque là puis je vais pas en
tout cas moi je t'écris mon père dit non
mais manifestement non parce qu'il va
rentrer encore en fait que je pense que
Ben du monde ne sont pas tannés mais moi
j'ai pas donné la ici la littérature
voilà j'ai dit c'est évidemment un
groupe qui donc il se frotte
complètement mon opinion ils ne
connaissent pas c'est assez safe je
n'aimerais pas de groupe québécois
Patrick c'est le cas merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup merci